[Music]
this is a Leviathan studio where we do
our yearly poetry it's amazing consider
coming but we're going to talk about
this this floor roll we're going to
learn it play going clockwise so they're
going to the right and you need to be
able to really control the horizontal
buzzsaw with the right elbow up left
elbow down and with the left elbow up
right elbow down and being able to
switch between them this is the
prerequisite passing through buzzsaw
over the top passing through buzzsaw
under the bottom first thing it's just
to a vertical buzzsaw backward with me
so facing the same direction and let the
left boy lead over the top then at the
bottom the right leads through you get
back to where you started so it's that
left play leading over the top that's
what we're gonna take onto the
horizontal plane the next important
thing is what the body does and this by
itself can really take practice I
learned this in a dance class by a
Feldenkrais teacher you start on the
ground with your right knee bent and if
you are not flexible to sit in this
position it's gonna be a little more
difficult than I'm not exactly sure how
to solve this so assuming you can sit
like this you can proceed to the next
step from here if I bend over that knee
and let my arm the elbow gently come to
the ground I relax and just roll across
my back legs come over the top and the
trick is really when I get this knee
comes down I just relax and keep rolling
and let the momentum gently bring me
back up when I show this to people often
they roll down and then they get to hear
it and they sold their way up and that
really won't work the the dance exercise
that I learned what's all about doing
this with on
no effort where you just relax and just
keep relaxing and see if you actually
don't do anything the momentum just
brings you back up into the mirror
position with the left knee bent you
switch and you're relaxed and again one
of the tricks is the head with practice
you can actually learn to very gently
lay your head in the ground for a moment
and that helps with relaxing your entire
body you want to be careful with that to
not bang your head into the ground the
floor Sara sprung dance floor so
actually that that helps with any
possible head banging but to be aware so
ideally want to get to where this is
pretty effortless you just relax relax
and then watch the arms as I relax down
the right arm comes to the ground the
left arm is on top so as I relax that
can draw a circle along the ground
followed by the right arm to get back to
here and that informant switch poi is
going to lead so from your horizontal
buzz saw with my I've got my left elbow
up that allows you to put the right
elbow on the ground as I start to lean
back that left arm can lead to the other
side and now I'm in a horizontal buzz
saw with my right arm on top so I
switched my legs the left point leads
under to switch the poi that's on top
and I can repeat
do do this well certainly takes practice
to make it look really good you want to
practice keeping employ a certain height
above the floor to really get a true
horizontal plane going I'm a bit rusty
at that so that's really it
the rest is practice and especially
about allowing everything to move in a
very circular arc and I'm starting to
keep the horizontal level equal to
create a visual plane and learning to
relax relax relax now from there I'm
sure if if any of you like some of you
are break dancers I bet you can build on
this and have a fancier way to roll on
the ground with maybe the legs kicking
and spinning
I haven't solved that yet but if you won
this up post a video because I would
love
[Music]